**clap**
meme review
*clap*
*still clapping*
*clapping insanely
meme review
brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Welcome everybody to meme review.
The show where we will go through all of the memes.
No matter how important or trivial the meme will be.
We will review it on my new original show . . .
Meme review
FIRST MEME . . .
Which is my favorite
It's the Ben Swol meme
It comes from Kylo Ren in Star Wars
Being topless for a few seconds in the latest movie Star Wars: [The Last] Jedi
Which was by the way if I may say so . . . The greatest Star Wars movie of all time.
I love the humor, I love the characters, but I especially love this one scene for five seconds
Where Kylo Ren appears with a high waist . . .
Like my god. How do you how do you get it that tall fam?
uhm...
*laughing*
With very tall waist and
He's his man's man sickles
Are ginormous. I remember watching this in the cinema
I turned over to Marzia and I said, "My God that man's breasts are . . .
GIGANTIC" I don't know if I'm disgusting or . . .*long pause [brain fart]
If I'm turned on and what was with the high waist?!
Naturally . . .*another brain fart
When you see something weird
People . . .
People exaggerate it
*awkward laugh*
I like this meme by the way, "What made you this way? *it's a birth defect
There we have him with Lena Dunham. Dunham(?) doesn't matter
Look how swole you've become
Something far worse has happened to you
The protein shakes, where did you hide them?
*dat laugh*
*awkwardly inhalling*
My God. How did he get so swole?
Kylo Ren's shirtless scene in The Last Jedi was weird
But, things really got out of hand when Luke Skywalker squeezed one of his four nipples and drank Kylos
unpasteurized, green milk. What happened in this movie? What went wrong, or should I say . . .
*Whispers* What went right?
My God. This was the Death Star. This is *inaudible* Starkiller base
I don't . . . I don't understand this one to be honest, but it shows you . . .*brain fart
That the man has giant boobs. S-he bet you he has bigger ones than her.
And it sort of makes you understand the free the nipple movement.
Why can Kylo Ren show his disgusting men stickles and women can't flaunt them in public?
Hashtag free the nipples here
Here, We have one of my favorite images
And it really captures the swollness of the Ben Swole.
You don't want to see what's happening here, but . . .
Can- Can I request an editor making me into the bench small right now?
*amazing edit*
The protein shakes. Where have you taken them?
That's no moon. It's Ben Swole
giggle
Here we have of course the crossover meme, the monkey haircut
You know we had to do it to him, petting dog meme, and reloading gun with battery meme? What the heck I don't
Sir, we're detecting a massive object emerging from hyperspace. It is Ben Swole everybody
These high waisted pants are to die for *yup
and look
We can add me into that meme
*no plis*
Now that's a fresh meme, boy, I prefer the real Supreme  Leader. I said the real Supreme Leader
perfection
Grandpappy what is it great see see it's not the first time
We've been blessed by nipples in Star Wars, but I do prefer
Ben's swoles someone made a Ben's swole in
in dark souls..
Of course you have to make all of them. This is this how memes work these days?
You know you gotta catch them all who would win my heterosexuality?
one wide boy
Have you bought my chair now this meme is fresh, it's
It's it's universal
And it is star wars I'm gonna rate this meme a 4., nah  yeah a 4.3
*gotta love dat music boii*
*meme incoming*
*told ya*
Next
meme. on Twitter
You may have seen these type of tweets if you play bring me to life by Evanescence at exactly eleven
5908 on New Year's Eve the first
Wake me up will play at exactly midnight start off your New Year's, right?
*done pewds*
This means started from a username a blonde ocean
Which which pointed out that if you start listening to nights by Frank Ocean on December 31st at this time?
The transitioning of the song will sync perfectly within the next year, so let's say you're playing
Brotha brofist song pewdiepie bro fist
*amazing song, am i right?*
By 1911 56 the first bro fist
Will start will be the first one of the year start your year, right?
Now this is a really good shit mean
Like the Evanescence one is funny, but
If you play stranger things theme song and December 31st
If you can live your 2018 like a stranger things episode you're welcome like I've got enough
Tentacles in my life. Thank you very much if you play star by Smash Mouth at exactly 11:15 9
The first hey now, we'll start exactly at midnight start to New Year's right
That's it. That's funny. Smash smash mouth is a funny meme
Everybody
Goochy goochy goochy games you can spread their ass on new China if you don't play a Gucci gang by 11:58
You will feel a lot better going into 2018. I'm gonna rate this meme a
Solid
Two and a half because I don't like it okay
I've seen other people trying to make this meme and you're not amusing me enough for you wanted to give it more than a two
And a half
Okay, it's too much text. Okay. It's like I have to have to laugh because I read all that text oh
Yes, I was mildly amusing next meme
Place the next meme is the probably one of the bigger memes of December the Thai political
crisis breakup meme
Now I didn't know
It took me a long time to find the original these meme apparently
It's a joke about having sex with a woman that supports this Thai
Politician I imagine it would be the same as going home to a woman and
Find out she has a picture of Hillary, Clinton
I
Don't know what the representation is but at the same time. That's the joke you know
I just noticed. There's a little weird guy in the balcony. That's funny here. We have another one of battlefront 2
Here we have the a AJIT PI one where fuck his wife like he fucks our cut
Here we have a AJIT spy going home with a woman sees the Internet
Well the edits on this one is creative, and I will give points for that I will not forget here here
We have this one where bike cuts. It's sort of a reverse one cuz my cook
Is upset that he's not getting cooked it took my a long time to figure out but props to you there
We have a man that just decides to recycle bottles
And here we have Mimi and Marcia look at that incoming call
Original content, I guess it's the same one really these are two different memes, but they are sort of the same thing
Reject your whamon?
Because you have a better call
Bonus meme!
We have time for bonus meme everybody. Consider yourself lucky.
The chairman of the FCC- I'm sure you've seen this god-awful video where he-
You know, in my previous video- I don't want to take credit, okay?
but in my video about net neutrality, I told- I told Ajit
I was like "Ajit, I don't understand what the point of retracting net neutrality is
You need to do a better job at explaining it to people so people understand"
That's what I said, and then all the sudden
He makes- all the sudden! huh! huh! huh! Ajit, I know you're watching this you f*cking weird- you f*cking... nerd. Got them.
Think- you're not gonna be able to watch me more, Ajit, if you ruining net neutrality *laugh*
Well Ajit decided "Well, I'm gonna make a BuzzFeed video"
Explaining why reducing net neutrality won't change anything
"Hi, I'm Ajit Pai. I'm the chairman of the FCC."
"Recently there's been quite a bit of conversation about my plan to restore Internet freedom"
"Here are just a few other things you'll still be able to do on the Internet"
"You can still drive meme right into the ground"
You can still ruin memes. As if the Harlem shake wasn't ruined already
but then he also had the- the wonderful bit where he is looking at 'Game of Thrones'
and the devil horns just can't have escaped him
and people thought "Wow! we can meme this!"
So people started adding Ajit Pai approving of different things.
Here we have Ajit Pai approving my best video on this channel...
'Drinking piss for views'
We have Ajit Pai watching his favorite show!
It's a 911 meme everybody. Now, that's pretty edgy.
We have Ajit Pai watching Ajit Pai. *laugh*
Here we have Ajit Pai watching one of the greatest song this year.
Ajit Pai reacting to Doki Doki meme
I'm gonna rate this meme a solid
It's almost a four but to be honest. I'm a bit tired of all this net neutrality shit.
Please- just stop...
Thank you for watching another episode of meme review.
Last one-hit trending. So, keep up the support. Check out my patreon link in the bottom. And as always-
*CLAP*
meme review™
Merry Christmas